on November 17th the California
Institute of Technology announced that
alumnus Ross m brown would be donating
$400 million nearly all of his fortune
to the university through what would be
called the Ross Brown investigators
program designed to support mid-level
physics and chemistry professors in
their quest to take on Bold initiatives
but there's an unusual element to the
generous gift the academics getting the
financial Awards won't be at Caltech
Brown who got his undergraduate degree
in mechanical engineering from Caltech
back in 1956 and a master's degree from
The Institute the following year is now
88 he founded industrial conglomerate
cogenic Industries in 1973 and sold it
for reported nearly 440 million in
2017 as to why he chose to donate so
much of his fortune Brown says at some
point I had to decide how I was going to
give back I didn't want to pass it on to
my children because I might have a big
risk of ruining their lives Brown the
father of seven children and Grand
grandfather of 16 adds I've seen too
many trust fund babies to ever want to
do that to my kids how best to give away
is Fortune then Brown wasn't sure at
first what he did know was he wanted to
focus on physics and chemistry Brown
told me the physical sciences are
underfunded and because Innovations in
these fields have the biggest impact on
the future so how did he start to narrow
his focus in 2018 he went looking for
further advice and contacted Mark
kassner then the president of the
science philanthropy Alliance nonprofit
group with the goal of encouraging more
charitable donations in science castner
suggested that brown consider funding
mid-level fundamental science
professors newly hired assistant
professors of science at top research
universities are well taken care of
typically with a 5 million startup
package but after they achiev tenure
those funds have been spent tenured
professors can apply for government
grants but in castner's view those are
typically not enough for professors to
try something different over roughly 18
months of talking to people working in
philanthropy Brown says he grew
concerned about the sector he sees two
problems a foundation drifting from its
original Mission and overhead getting
out of
control then someone suggested having a
university with aligned interests run
the program which would ideally solve
both the mission drift and the cost
control
challenges this is the first large gift
of its kind where the recipient of the
donation will turn around and give
nearly all of it to faculty at other
universities
Caltech won't be eligible to receive any
of the investigator Awards Brown
explains just because of the conflict of
interest nor will they be allowed to sit
on the science Advisory board so it's
really in caltech's general interest in
science itself that has led them to get
to where they are Caltech will
administer the program while an
independent review board will choose
eight fellows annually from more than a
dozen invited universities across the
country each chosen investigator will
receive a $2 million 5 year Fellowship
Caltech aims to administer the program
until 2070 assuming sufficient Returns
on invested funds Brown is Bucking a
trend in choosing to fund the physical
sciences rather than the life sciences
Brown says 85% of funding in the United
States for basic research of some kind
goes to Life Sciences only 15% ends up
in the physical sciences or non-life
Sciences cner points out that Government
funding in the two areas leans the same
way if you look at Government funding
it's also tilted very heavily towards
biomedical research Brown admits this is
a bit of a gamble given that it's the
first program like it but he's
optimistic adding if you could just get
25% of what you're putting in being
foundational for somebody else's work
later to make my grandchildren's life
better I'm for
[Music]
that